tout à l'heure des gens sont venus me
voir en me disant c'est un montage c'est
truqué tu peux nous prouver le contraire
tu peux reproduire le dessin de cette
affiche ben je vais te montrer quelques
techniques de travail que je fais donc
pour les films et je vais te prendre
comme partenaire moi ouh là c'était pas
prévu du tout ça mais pas du tout prévu
est-ce que quelqu'un veut venir à ma
place
pas de volontaire curieusement bon on
reste amis alors tu bouges pas on se
tient la main c'est un mouvement donc de
stretching dextérité lentement slow
motion niveau milieu là et puis le
niveau là je reste à mon aise le soleil
va il fait chaud super et alors il y a
des mouvements qui sont plus rapides
comme ceci ne bouge pas
j'ai senti le vent ou encore un autre ne
bouge pas avec le micro là
et alors le grand écart
voilà pour ceux qui pensaient que
c'était une photo truquée